we're going a bit of a lighter topic
where's the poop there's not enough poop
in this episode i just [ __ ] myself
so i've been addicted to like a new type
of video recently like oh i know what
you tweeted about yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's like it's like sometimes sometimes
the youtube algorithm just works in like
mysterious ways right you know what you
know what a story that starts off with
that sentence isn't going to lead to
anything yeah it's so like like
grandiose so like i uh i i get this
video recommended on my youtube which is
like oh uh
someone sharing cow hooves and like they
get instant relief from bubbles oh my
gosh
yes i'm just watching them too
so i was like i was like what the [ __ ]
what what is this what is why why why
does youtube think i'm gonna be
interested in cowboys i i have that
section of like videos that i would
never subscribe for but are pleasantly
surprising when i watch them yeah stuff
like restoration uh cleaning cars yeah
um
there was one that was like testing
mouse traps
and this guy worked on a farm and he
just had like every single goddamn mouse
trap on yeah yeah and it was just like
weirdly like like weirdly like kind of
like oh that's cool how the trap works
yeah so i'm watching my style so i kind
of feel bad i feel i feel the same way
about like guys who are in like massive
ant farms and stuff like that
that makes me so anxious yeah whole
living it's like damn like
but i've got
yeah i remember just watching the
cowherd videos and i was i've never been
i've never seen something that i've been
that is like disgusting but weirdly
relaxing as well it's it's yes this it's
because that [ __ ] comes off so clean
it's it comes off so clean and just it's
kind of like you know it's it's kind of
like scratching an itch or something
like that you know where she's like see
your videos
yeah just just
like
seeing the seeing the pus come out of
like the cowl hooves it's like
disgusting but like for some for some
reason when you see the words instant
relief in the title you're just like i'm
happy for the cow man i'm i'm happy at
least the cows have here
something of something about instant
relief in the title it's just like i
feel better now i feel better for the
couch it's disgusting what you should
just do with cows if we did we're doing
this were they just like chilling just
with their like disgusting toes yeah
they were just like just you know
standing out in the paddock just chewing
grasping like well i'm in insufferable
pain right now but you know what am i
[ __ ] gonna [ __ ] yeah because
because like i got like evolution kind
of [ __ ] up there like my feet don't
just collect [ __ ] yeah i'm unable to
clean them yeah because like these these
cow hooves are like [ __ ] hard because
what they have to do used to shear them
is like razor sharp and they can like
barely barely get through them so how
the [ __ ] these cows can survive without
humans is just beyond me because i've
seen some of the cow videos put them in
like [ __ ] cages
maybe the reason why like you know when
cows tip over and they can't get up it's
not because they can't get us because
they don't want to [ __ ] get they're
like oh
my god
when my feet breathe jesus because like
i imagine it it's just like the worst
ingrown toenail you've ever had but you
don't have anything to cut it yeah and
like i've had some pretty bad ingrown
toenails so i feel some kind of
spiritual connection to the cow just
seeing this pus come out right if if god
wouldn't make a video like that he'd put
like instant relief hashtag relatable
say oh [ __ ] if it's relatable yeah i
feel you cow
me using a toilet instantly
satisfying
30 minute conversation are you using
different bidets
instant relief
hashtag relatable this one is very
special